[Música]
Un saludo para la audiencia Mi nombre es
Ángela Gómez y aquí comienza ella es hoy
el programa feminista de France 24 en
los últimos años se han reportado cada
vez más casos de mujeres que eligen como
anticonceptivo un método permanente la
ligadura de sus trompas la decisión de
no ser madres está cada vez más afirmada
pero a veces también es consecuencia de
las dificultades para obtener un aborto
voluntario o un contraceptivo en este
programa vamos a explorar estos y
también otros argumentos Comencemos
viendo el informe de Gabriel colchón
en Estados Unidos desde la revocación
del caso rovers weight en junio pasado y
la limitación del derecho al aborto que
lo siguió muchas mujeres llegaron a las
clínicas para practicar una ligadura de
trompas en Texas por ejemplo donde el
aborto está prohibido Incluso en caso de
violación la doctora Michelle reportó el
año pasado al medio Los Ángeles Times
que ahora atiende diariamente a mujeres
para esterilizaciones he tenido más
consultas para esterilizaciones en
volumen por carga de pacientes que nunca
en mi carrera nunca antes había visto a
tantas mujeres en tal estado de pánico o
ansiedad sobre sus cuerpos y sus
derechos reproductivos en Colombia son
cada vez más las jóvenes en elegir este
método anticonceptivo las que tienen
Entre 25 y 29 años representan alrededor
del 27% de las pacientes que se sometan
a esta práctica en el país entre las
razones que exponen el fin de la
concepción de la maternidad como destino
natural la crisis climática o las
condiciones económicas en Argentina una
ley de 2006 incluso proteger el derecho
a este anticonceptivo definitivo desde
los 16 años todas las personas pueden
elegir y optar libremente sin necesidad
de asistencia alguna por este método
anticonceptivo a partir de los 16 años
de edad pero en la práctica mujeres de
varios países reportan sufrir de
estigmatización Especialmente cuando
toman la decisión siendo jóvenes cuando
tienen menos de 30 años y no han tenido
hijos puede tomar años encontrar a un
médico que acepte practicar la
intervención finalmente hay que recordar
que en muchos países del continente hay
al menos dos veces más mujeres que optan
por este procedimiento que hombres que
optan por la vasectomía una operación
anticonceptiva definitiva masculina que
es más sencilla y segura que la ligadura
de trompas para las mujeres y para
conversar sobre este tema está en ella
soy Laura Gil ella es ginecóloga de la
Universidad Nacional de Colombia y
directora del grupo médico por el
derecho a decidir Laura un gusto
saludarla Gracias por estar en ellas hoy
Hola Muchísimas gracias a ustedes por
invitarme bueno Laura comienzo
preguntándole Por qué van en aumento a
las esterilizaciones voluntarias de
mujeres jóvenes
yo creo que hay una base que va mucho
más allá de la situación política del
aborto de todo lo que estamos viendo
últimamente y tiene que ver con que cada
vez más la maternidad se interpreta no
tanto como un evento biológico como el
destino de una mujer o como el factor
que Define una mujer y se define se ve
mucho más como un proyecto de vida como
una elección como una decisión que puede
tomar cada mujer y que no la define como
mujer
creo que hoy en día nuestra cultura y
nuestra sociedad está mucha más abierta
a esa decisión Qué pasa que hay
coyunturas como por ejemplo lo que nos
acabas de mostrar en las que si no hay
acceso a una forma efectiva y real de
evitar la maternidad pueda que las
mujeres se sientan abocadas a tomar la
decisión de esterilizarse y pues pueda
que muchas de ellas hayan tenido ya la
decisión de que su proyecto de vida no
es ser madre si por lo tanto es una
decisión absoluta entendible y factible
Bueno en ese sentido entonces
continuemos por ahí Laura Qué opina
usted del acceso o de la disponibilidad
de métodos anticonceptivos o
profesionales de la salud debidamente
capacitados que puedan indicar a una
mujer las opciones que tiene para llevar
adelante sus derechos sexuales y
reproductivos e incluso las
restricciones de aborto como todo esto
influye Pues en lo que será la vida
sexual y los derechos de reproducción de
una mujer a lo largo de su vida claro es
que siempre que hablamos de
anticoncepción pensamos en un acto
médico pensamos en el método en las
pastillas en la cirugía pero la
anticoncepción y todo lo que está
alrededor de las decisiones
reproductivas más que un método y más
que algo técnico y científico son todas
las herramientas que tiene una mujer
para decidir sobre cómo quiere vivir su
vida entonces no puede ser visto como un
simple acto médico o como simplemente
explicarle a una persona Cómo funcionan
los métodos anticonceptivos sino con que
se haga todo un proceso de la
información necesaria para esa persona
adaptada a esa persona completa y que
permita que la persona tome decisiones
libremente y de tomar una decisión libre
y autónomamente que hace parte de los
derechos fundamentales de los humanos
Pero además de los derechos sexuales y
reproductivos incluye tener toda esa
información y tener el espacio para
decidir sin juzgamientos Entonces por
ejemplo la ligar o a trompas es uno de
esos métodos que afortunadamente existe
pero que tiene que y que tienen que
estar al alcance de las personas siempre
y cuando tengan toda la información
necesaria para tomar una decisión
informada y cuando llega el momento de
tomar esa decisión Laura quisiera
también que nos hablara un poco desde su
práctica profesional como Hay muchísimas
otras razones que pueden intervenir en
la decisión de una ligadura de trompas
para definitivamente bloquear la
posibilidad de una maternidad porque un
tema es la ansiedad por anticonceptivos
o por métodos de aborto pero también hay
mujeres que aluden a causas climáticas
hay mujeres o personas gestantes que
están aludiendo a enfermedades que no
quisieran tener la posibilidad de
transmitir a sus hijos a que somos
muchas personas en el mundo etcétera
etcétera y todas estas son causas que si
bien no son nuevas en el mundo si es
nuevo ponerlas sobre la mesa en una
conversación
claro es que tú lo has dicho las causas
son infinitas O sea no las podemos
clasificar en suficientes o
insuficientes o poderosas o poco
poderosas porque la decisión de maternar
es tan profundamente privada e
individual y basada en motivos de
conciencia que cualquiera de esas
razones que pueda digamos esgrimir una
mujer es válida porque tiene que ver con
una decisión de vida con un proyecto de
vida entonces qué quiere decir esto que
realmente desde el servicio de salud lo
que nosotros tenemos que estar digamos
pendientes o evaluando no es las razones
que tenga la mujer porque cualquiera que
tenga la mujer es válida de lo que
tenemos que estar absolutamente seguros
es de que esa mujer o esa persona cuenta
con la información suficiente que le
permita tomar esa decisión de manera
adecuada es decir que sepa que el
requisito realmente para mí como lo veo
desde mi vida profesional y desde mi
experiencia es que entienda que esta es
una decisión permanente que esta es una
decisión que es válida Es válido no
querer ser madre o no querer maternar o
paternar a futuro que esa decisión se
puede tomar en muchos momentos de la
vida ya sea muy joven sin tener hijos o
cuando ya se han tenido los hijos que se
han querido incluso más pero que siempre
es válida siempre y cuando se entienda
que es una decisión permanente muchas
mujeres me ha pasado que piensan que se
pueden ligar y después desligar o
incluso Los hombres también que se
pueden operar y después pueden revertir
la cirugía y Sí existen técnicas para
revertirlas pero por lo general son
costosas poco eficientes entonces para
mí realmente no es que se tenga una u
otra razón porque para mí todas las
razones son válidas es que se entienda
que es una decisión definitiva y que es
respetable que es respetable no querer
tener hijos por diferentes razones
muchas veces se dice no es que las
mujeres están en pánico están en
ansiedad porque se cuestiona esa
capacidad de tomar una decisión a largo
plazo y se le adjudica al miedo a la
ansiedad a la desinformación a la
posibilidad de arrepentirse más adelante
y creo que eso tiene que ver mucho con
ese problema que tenemos de no creer en
las decisiones que toman las mujeres de
no creer que las mujeres son capaces de
decidir sobre sus propios cuerpos y
sobre Su futuro bueno Laura Usted cree
que la ligadura de trompas podría ser
también una forma de contrarrestar
ejercicios de poder y ejercicios de
control sobre el cuerpo de las mujeres y
se lo pregunto a partir de de una
historia personal
que realmente no es mía sino es la
historia de un amigo practicando
partos en zonas rurales a manera de
servicio social y que se encontró con la
experiencia de mujeres que le suplicaron
que después del parto les ligar a las
trompas sin que nadie más fuera de esa
sala de partos se enterara especialmente
sus parejas sentimentales o sus maridos
y pues eran casos de mujeres que ya
tenían muchos hijos y que ya no querían
seguir pariendo más pero pero sorprende
mucho que estas tenga que ser como
tantas otras decisiones de la intimidad
de las mujeres tomada en secreto y se
diría por debajo de cuerda
por supuesto existen existe toda una
historia de cómo la el control de la
fertilidad de las mujeres a a
contribuido precisamente a ese control
económico y esa inequidad de las mujeres
Entonces sí es un recurso muchas mujeres
se ven enfrentadas a tenerse que ligar
sin el apoyo o sin el consentimiento Por
así decirlo porque no necesitan el
consentimiento de su compañero y es la
única forma que encuentran de controlar
sus cuerpos Y esto no Debería ser así O
sea ya deberían estar en la posibilidad
de compartir esta decisión de tomar la
Autónoma nuevamente sin tenerla que
tomar en en secreto porque esto va en
contra del derecho a la dignidad y el
derecho a la libertad de las mujeres
Entonces sí claro que sí es un ejercicio
de poder recuperar ese control sobre el
cuerpo que es lo que estamos viendo un
poco cuando las mujeres Ven por ejemplo
que ya no va a haber acceso al aborto
como lo habían Estados Unidos y puede
verse restringido también ellas pueden
tomar ese control a través de la
ligadura de trompas si es que están
seguras que a futuro desean tener ningún
hijo y el otro tema relacionado con esto
y que tiene que ver un poco con las
relaciones de pareja y como la
anticoncepción tiene que ser una
responsabilidad también compartida así
como el cuidado Debería ser una
responsabilidad compartida
quisiera Laura que por favor nos
explicara Esa diferencia entre la
vasectomía y la ligadura de trompas
Porque es importante tener desde su
práctica la explicación de cómo el
cuerpo de una mujer puede verse mucho
más afectado por una operación
anticonceptiva que pues que el de un
hombre por supuesto Y esta es una verdad
gigante que parece no influir en las
decisiones de las parejas la cirugía
para un hombre es una cirugía mucho
menos invasiva que no implica un acceso
al abdomen implica un acceso al escroto
y tiene mucho menos mucho menos riesgo
de complicaciones y de hecho a largo
plazo es tiene mucho menos posibilidad
de falla que la ligadura de trompas sin
embargo casi siempre es la mujer la que
tiene que tomar la decisión de
esterilizarse porque el hombre tiene
temor hay mitos tiene miedo de que se va
a influenciar su vida sexual y es la
mujer la que se somete a la cirugía y
esto nos demuestra un poco esa
desigualdad Y esa Y esa esa ese peso que
tienen que cargar las mujeres cuando no
se ve el anticoncepción como tú lo has
dicho como una cosa de pareja no como
una responsabilidad única de las mujeres
pues mire Laura Yo le agradezco mucho
usted nos ha ayudado a resolver algunas
dudas y aclarar algunos conceptos que
son más que necesarios para poder
empoderarnos de nuestra vida sexual y
reproductiva Ya se nos acaba el tiempo
pero seguro que este es un tema que
podemos invitar a las mujeres y a las
personas que está antes para que se
sigan informando sobre Qué es lo mejor
según cada caso particular Muchísimas
gracias a usted a ustedes Muchas gracias
el agradecimiento como siempre es
también para nuestros televidentes sigan
en France 24 y nos vemos Próximamente en
ellas hoy
[Música]